hello and welcome to the new world
review I'm grand line waifu and today
i'm putting on my glasses because this
is that whatever time it is wherever you
are news this episode will contain many
a spoiler there may be liberal use of
the word karateka there may be many
reflections on the beauty that is melody
melody deserves your thumbs up liam
trolling me deserves your thumbs down
let's see those thumbs up liam
no trolling because it will result in an
immediate thumbs down today we're
discussing episodes 44 and 45 of honda
hunter and prying it open to suck out
the juicy juicy musical story within and
his tompa in the field ah I think you
you'll find I've been gone for at least
one full up could you untie me please
I'll give you a poopy beverage and that
was tompa remember him me neither
let's head into the field again this
time over to karappa Koh who has eyes on
the situation kora pika
red eyes very red eyes errotica let's
skip the news and ahead to the spoilers
episode 44 setting up an arena of bodies
we watch the best of the best hash it
out or theoretically anyway it was
really enjoyable seeing the surprise on
each of the faces as they pulled out
some of their stronger abilities and got
to work trying to defeat their foe there
was more of the gore that we saw in the
last episode but to see our Wolverine
friend who VOAD aside to have a Goku s
Super Saiyan moment was pretty
fascinating it's becoming pretty clear
that the original exam was the thymus
thing we're going to see of this series
though there's just a lot of ik to deal
with gore isn't a problem for me but
it's interesting to see the progression
and how that progression is happening
with this series compared to say Pokemon
or Harry Potter in Harry Potter every
book got progressively darker until the
climax and in Pokemon well ash just won
something good job ash here we haven't
even had enough episodes to get through
an entire year and our audience must
have aged up in order to really
comprehend both the intensity of the
emotions why they're happening and the
gore that they're being exposed to I'm
not a parent but it would be interesting
trying to navigate the clear changes and
what I'd guess we'd call darkness some
people used Gore as a measure which is
why I keep bringing it up of how awful
people are I use the concept the gore
stands for the fact that everyone
involved was grossed out by the idea of
the leeches was entertaining but there
was more to it than that it made clear
how icky the concept was but
and they qualified it in a way that only
someone mature enough to understand pain
and how it works would really be
affected by it and there's something
about hunter hunter that I really like
him this way the fact that like a Disney
movie there's something for everyone
young kids love color and sound this
show has color and sound
it also has gore teenagers often revel
in gore then it has the depth of emotion
and the variations in art form to make
it appeal to adults and I really
appreciate all of those aspects speaking
of emotional depth when that phantom
troupe tattoo was revealed in Caracas
heartbeat escalated I thought things
were gonna go down right there and then
I thought all sorts of things were about
to become a serious problem because
could out because in the opening credits
were they about to pull a game of
Thrones on me and kill him off what
happens when he sees his soakers fake
tattoo and tries to use his chains on
him that's a serious issue given he's
attached himself to them hmm I'm sure
we'll come back to that and if we don't
what were they thinking at first I
thought the rest of the trip just didn't
care if Wolverine lived or died that was
my first assumption then I realized they
do care they actually do care even if
it's just pride they know he can handle
himself or at least they suspected he
could they didn't think it was possible
for anyone else to kidnap one of them
yet here we are
good job karateka you're crazy but we're
not there yet
right now let's discuss the fight
between ovo and the recently deceased
shadow beasts first things first
everyone was grossed out by the leeches
right not just me okay good
depositing eggs in someone's stomach you
we're still earring together right good
yeah
the shadow beasts like everyone else who
has some kind of power in the show
apparently other than the melody seems
to enjoy torturing people sure they have
their different flavors crap occur likes
to torture tropas GaN likes to torture
anyone it would be fun to see flounder
Hisoka likes to torture those who get
his Schwing going but this level of
torture is eventually their downfall why
well I was watching that wonderfully
camp movie van Helsing last night the
one with Hugh Jackman Kate Beckinsale's
character I forget her name um Anna has
this great line I think if you're going
to kill someone do it don't just stand
there talking about it it's artistically
fun to find ways to give an audience
torture apparently but it leaves one
very open to someone literally biting
your face off it seems odd that they
didn't expect that could be a thing to
be fair I also didn't consider that that
could be a thing so maybe I'm not wanted
something I'm interested in is the shift
in art as we now know what Ren looks
like and how it's used
there's no need anymore to show it being
used unless it's very specifically more
powerful than the people being affected
by it or if it's an extraordinary usage
I'll give you a moment to like go over
that cuz yeah
I don't know if I was that did I confuse
myself I'm also interested in the way
we're using music to add to the creepy
vibe and now that the music is being
manipulated by melody there's this
beautiful meta aspect to it in which we
can fool ourselves into thinking she can
hear all the orchestration of this show
the vocals sliding and harmonics
involved in seeing the shadow beast
defeated was intense the use of voices
in there rather than instruments was
reminiscent of the fact that there are
actually people here observing there's
an audience and they're all afraid and
concerned by what's happening then
there's a sound wave and everything gets
worse everything gets more heightened it
makes everything so clear cut out
because very quickly learning that it's
important to know who you're fighting
know who you're up against but first
first he loses it and melody brings he
and everyone else back from all the
different emotions they're having seeing
that made me wonder how she would deal
with his sound situation the the sound
wave a sonic boom sort of thing but also
whether she could do it if she herself
is distressed by what's happening the
only thing we've seen of melody is
concern not distress we haven't seen her
panic and I'm kind of interested in what
that would look like I have one more
thing to say for now for this episode
anyway the restraining middle finger is
the most metal thing I've ever heard
linking it to your own heart is the most
metal thing I've ever heard and is
incredibly dangerous but hey more
recklessness is exactly what we need all
he needs is some more hair gel and maybe
some sharper lines to a special dress
and he's ready to go just like me on to
episode 45 the shadow beasts are no more
the silhouettes we were introduced to
about two episodes ago were basically
useless other than to highlight how
powerful these foes are honestly they
did that job to an okay degree the major
issue with them was that they were just
silhouettes and we had no real emotional
connection to them how powerful they
were was simply because we were told
they were powerful we had no knowledge
of what they might actually be and how
they might actually act in real life
generally Hunter Hunter has a great show
Don't Tell appeal but I
think that might be why I so dislike the
liberal use of silhouettes to describe
power we got shown some faces and just
as quickly those faces were gone they
literally dived in Marvel style and
that's all we saw of them until a magic
vacuum cleaner was contemplating eating
them
that owl could shrink people was a great
comedy interlude especially since nava
nava none I'm bad with names nob no
longer had literally just complained
about the fact that they were all in a
small car there was a really interesting
point around here though when he got out
he yelled at them and was admonished for
doing so it seems there's a very
specific rule set involved in being part
of the Phantom troupe despite the idea
that killing another troupe member gets
you in do you get to choose it would be
interesting if Crocker kills a member of
the troupe whether he's offered the
opportunity to join because that's what
we're building up to right the idea that
he's got a very solid enemy in who go
VIN now and Wolverine wants him dead
because he's managed to both kidnap and
actually punch through his nen hardcore
Karaka is very clearly developing very
quickly his ability to read Wolverine
combined with his complete lack of care
of his own well-being he doesn't need to
fear his rage running out but maybe his
time there was something very concerning
about seeing him catching his breath in
the hallway I'll come back to the
effective music soon but melody seeing
him breathing and smiling at her seemed
to cause concern in her and it caused
concern in me too is Karaka learning to
control his heartbeat around everyone in
general or is he genuinely calming down
that's the real question at the moment
because there's looking calm presenting
calm and being calm he could look calm
and smile he could seem calm and smile
but he could then break immediately and
surprise attack literally anyone that's
a frightening power and I think melody
knows that as someone whose power is to
assess heartbeat she's the only one at
president who knows exactly what's going
on in caracas body if he can change that
at will I sense problems now back to the
music the themes of this episode were
fantastic the hardcore karateka metal of
slamming into a go ovens nose straight
through the nen or did the spider
Letterman know it seems korabik I was so
fast that he didn't have time to stop it
from happening hence his ego feeling
bruised and he's been dead to starting
back in that hallway before kropog I
even started breathing melodies theme
was present
suggesting that either Cora picker was
thinking of it or that she was nearby in
this case we don't know which because
she did in fact turn up I didn't miss
however the haunting violin at the end
which reminded us of the dark sonata
that Melody's trying to deal with I do
wonder what the link is to Cora packing
this does it have to do with the fact
that korabik is hunting something she
perceives to be incredibly dangerous or
is it because this hunt connects the two
of them possibly both but the use of
Melody's flute theme combined with the
strings really amped up the stakes in
the moment despite it being a really
simple situation all korabik I was doing
was answering his phone
we knew it was to meet her soca but it
was more than that it's the intent
behind that and then add to that the
operatic tones that came through one
score a pack had gone and we have the
overture to a massacre or at least I
thought so instead only the boss is dead
he really should have recognized when
they said the shadow bees never stood a
chance he even tweaked to it and
questioned it didn't change his behavior
or act in any way suspicious oh well
he's dead now - wait he's dead - now
he's hmm and Cora Paco is apparently at
Luna Park which is a really boring
fairground in Sydney with a hiss oka
like face as the logo I mean look at
that look at it it's basically Hisoka
maybe that's why I've always found it
creepy it looks down on you like and
basically has a swing at you while you
walk in
speaking of Swing we got a bit of an
info dump again but this time the info
dump was quick and clean and I really
appreciated that I suspected my love is
in fact not a pedophile he just wants to
fight people because he likes to fight
people and who can blame him for that
the idea that the members could change
very quickly doesn't seem to ring true
especially given what we've seen of them
and how they seem to look after each
other that said if he so could took one
out casually a few years back maybe
that's why they're so careful to look
after each other I found it interesting
that their focus is on stealing killing
and philanthropy so they have a website
what's their philosophy do they have
like an about Us page of all the things
I would have expected if this group of
people that's not it
there having said that given who Govan
was okay with letting the others go if
he was being genuine maybe that actually
is something they do too late now
Wolverine's real mad at kora pika so mad
he used his abs to break out of metal
braces and his head to smash through a
doorway that is a man who won
out and I'm gonna follow his lead since
he left such a big opening and say
that's it from me if you enjoyed what
you've heard and want to see more click
on this thing this thing maybe this
click on this grab a sandwich and have a
great day